>> THERE’S SO MANY THINGS THAT
HAVE BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ALREADY,
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
I THINK THERE’S A GENERAL
UNDERSTANDING AMONG ALL
REPUBLICANS THAT WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING.
>> WE DON’T HAVE TIME TO WASTE
HERE AND IT’S SOMETHING THAT WE
BELIEVE COULD PASS OUR CHAMBER
AND IN THE HOUSE.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT, THAT WAS A SIGN
OF THINGS TO COME WHEN I HAD A
CHANCE TO SPEAK WITH BOTH
PROMINENT DEMOCRATIC SENATORS,
AND REPUBLICAN SENATORS, AS WELL
AS A NUMBER OF
CONGRESSMEN AND WOMEN BOTH
PARTIES OPEN TO A $900 BILLION
STIMULUS MEASURE, THAT WOULD GO
A LONG WAY TOWARD PROVIDING
EMERGENCY RELIEF RIGHT NOW,
BEFORE THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
TAKES OFFICE ON JANUARY 20.
LET’S GET A FAIR AND BALANCED
READ ON HOW LIKELY THAT IS, WITH
REPRESENTATIVE JESSIE JOHNSON
REPUBLICAN FROM SOUTH DAKOTA AND
REPRESENTATIVE DEAN PHILLIPS
DEMOCRAT FROM MINNESOTA.
GENTLEMAN WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU
AND THANK YOU FOR TAKING THE
TIME.
CONGRESSMAN PHILLIPS IF I CAN
BEGIN WITH YOU.
THIS IDEA THAT THIS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT FOR THIS , WHERE IS THE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT?
IN OTHER WORDS WHAT ARE THE
FEATURES THAT YOU AGREE
SHOULD BE ENACTED RIGHT NOW,
RATHER THAN WAIT UNTIL NEXT YEAR
WHEN JOE BIDEN TAKES OVER?
>> WELL, NEIL IF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THE MARCH TO COMMON
GROUND PLAN THAT MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE DUSTY JOHNSON WHOSE ON
RIGHT NOW WITH ME, HELPED CO-
LEAD AND DEVELOP SOME A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO, IF YOU LOOK
AT THE NEW BIPARTISAN PLAN THAT
WE WORKED WITH SENATORS ON JUST
INTRODUCED A FEW DAYS AGO YOU’LL
SEE THAT THERE’S A LOT OF
AGREEMENT SO TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION DIRECTLY, I THINK WE
MADE GREAT PROGRESS AND LOOK,
NOBODY IS GOING TO GET
EVERYTHING THEY WANT AND TO
THOSE WHO HAVE LOST FAITH IN
GOVERNMENT, I TELL YOU THE
ANECDOTE A THE PROBLEM
SOLVER’S CAUCUS AND DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS WORKING TOGETHER
TO FIND COMMON GROUND AND THAT’S
EXACTLY WHAT WE DID AND NOW IT’S
UP TO SOME OTHERS IN THE HOUSE
AND SENATE AND I HAVE CONFIDENCE
WE’LL GET IT DONE.
NEIL: NO I’M VERY IMPRESSED WITH
THE CAUCUS BECAUSE YOU TRY TO
PUT POLITICS ASIDE AND AT LEAST
FIND COMMON GROUND AND IT LOOKS
LIKE ENOUGH HAS BEEN FOUND THAT
YOU HAVE, SO CONGRESSMAN JOHNSON
, TO YOU ON THAT.
DO YOU THINK THERE’S ENOUGH
COMMON GROUND THAT THIS WILL
PASS?
>> I ABSOLUTELY THINK IT’S
GOING TO PASS.
IT NEEDS TO PASS.
THE REALITY IS 778,000 AMERICANS
FILED FOR UNEMPLOYMENT FOR THE
FIRST TIME LAST WEEK,
AND WE HAD 10,000 OF OUR COUNTRY
MEN DIE AND I THINK, NEIL
, YOU SEE THAT EVERY HOUR
THAT GOES BY, ANOTHER PROMINENT
LEGISLATIVE LEADER STEPS UP AND
ADDS THEIR VOICE TO OURS, AND
FRANKLY, THIS THING LOOKED DEAD
A WEEK AGO BUT SINCE WE MADE OUR
ANNOUNCEMENT ON TUESDAY ALL OF
THE MOMENTUM IS HEADED TOWARD
PASSAGE.
NEIL: JOE BIDEN HAS OFFERED
INSIGHT AND THINKING ON THIS AND
I THINK CONGRESSMAN PHILLIPS,
WHAT HE WAS SAYING, IS HE’D LIKE
TO SEE THAT $1,200 STIMULUS
CHECK THAT WAS OBVIOUSLY VERY
POPULAR IN THE INITIAL PANDEMIC
RELIEF PLAN.
I DON’T BELIEVE IT’S PART OF
THIS ONE YET.
DO YOU THINK IT WILL BE?
>> YOU KNOW, NEIL, TIME WILL
TELL OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT WAS
VERY MUCH IN FAVOR OF DIRECT
STIMULUS CHECKS IN THE PAST.
I BELIEVE THAT CONSUMPTION IS
THE ENGINE OF THE ECONOMY AND
MONEY AND PEOPLE’S POCKETS IS
THE FUEL, AND IN TIMES LIKE
THESE I DO BELIEVE THAT SENDING
MONEY TO PEOPLE DIRECTLY WHO ARE
STRUGGLING THE MOST IS A NET
BENEFIT TO THE ECONOMY, ACTUALLY
WILL COST LESS NOW THAN IT WILL
DOWN THE ROAD SO I AM IN FAVOR
OF IT.
WE WEREN’T ABLE TO ACHIEVE
EVERYTHING THAT EVERYBODY WANTED
IN THE CURRENT FRAMEWORK, BUT
I’M STILL HOPEFUL THAT COULD, IF
IT FINDS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
COULD BE ACHIEVED BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY FAVOR IT.
NEIL: CONGRESSMAN JOHNSON, I
TALKED TO YOUR REPUBLICAN
COUNTERPART IN THE SENATE, CHUCK
GRASSLEY, WHO WAS SAYING, YOU
KNOW, HE’S OPEN TO THIS , HE’S
OPEN TO A LOT OF IT BUT DON’T GO
CRAZY ON ANOTHER EFFORT THAT BE
JUST AS EXPENSIVE IF NOT MORE
EXPENSIVE LET’S SEE HOW THIS
GOES.
ARE YOU IN THAT CAMP THAT YOU’RE
OPEN TO MAYBE THIS , BUT NO MORE
MULTI TRILLION DOLLAR RELIEF
DOWN THE ROAD?
>> WELL, I MEAN, THERE ARE LOTS
OF VOICES THAT WANT TO ADD MORE
TO THIS PACKAGE BUT THE REALITY
IS THIS IS THE NUMBER THAT CAN
GET DONE.
I THINK AS YOU MAKE THE PACKAGE
A LOT LARGER, YOU LOSE A TON OF
REPUBLICANS
IF YOU MAKE IT A LOT SMALLER YOU
LOSE A TON OF DEMOCRATS.
IF POLITICS IS THE ART OF THE
POSSIBLE, AND IT IS, THIS IS
THE RIGHT PACKAGE, AND I VOTED
AGAINST, YOU KNOW, BIG
$3 TRILLION PACKAGES AND
$2 TRILLION PACKAGES AND PACKAGE
S THAT THE SPEAKER HAD
PUT ON THE FLOOR IN THE PAST.
THIS IS THE THING THAT CAN GET
DONE.
THIS IS THE DEAL THAT CAN BRING
SOME HOUSING AND NUTRITION AND
UNEMPLOYMENT AND PAYCHECK
PROTECTION RELIEF TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
LET’S GET THIS THING DONE.
FRANKLY, NEIL, I CAN’T BELIEVE
IT WASN’T DONE TWO OR  THREE
MONTHS AGO.
I MEAN IF DEMOCRATS LIKE DEAN
PHILLIPS AND REPUBLICANS LIKE
DUSTY JOHNSON WHO ARE
RANK-AND-FILE MEMBERS CAN COME
TO AGREEMENT ON THIS , WHY IN
THE WORLD CAN OUR LEADERSHIP NOT
DO IT?
I MEAN, I JUST FEEL LIKE THEY
LET POLITICS GET IN THE WAY.
LET’S GET THIS THING DONE AND
908 IS THE RIGHT NUMBER.
IT’S HIGHER THAN I WANT BUT IT’S
THE ONE THAT CAN GET DONE.
NEIL: ALL RIGHT, WE’LL WATCH
VERY CLOSELY, GENTLEMEN I WANT
TO THANK YOU BOTH, HOPE SPRINGS
ETERNAL FOR BIPARTISAN SUPPORT,
IT IS POSSIBLE, SO WE’LL SEE